from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between tgi fridays in the uk and the us
this is food wars
let's start with the starters now tgi
fridays in the uk and the us both have
lots of starter options so what we're
gonna do is pick the most popular ones
and compare those first up we have the
mozzarella sticks
an order of these in the uk contains
four sticks
in the u.s our tgi friday's mozzarella
sticks come in an order of six
six sticks or you can get the platter
which doubles that
12 sticks we're gonna weigh three uk
mozzarella sticks to try and find the
average weight
hey harry is that three sticks
i thought we thought that order had four
so three mozzarella six in the uk
weighed 95 grams that means that each
individual mozzarella stick weighed an
average of 31.6 grams
yes
so six sticks is 206 grams so that's
roughly 43 point repeating three grams
per stick
now pro tip weigh your food
[Music]
then try one
[Music]
fridays is running running the
mozzarella cheesesteak game the running
the mad stick game
the uk does have loaded potato skins but
they're not currently serving them gtv
pandemic because they don't travel very
well for delivery however we were able
to find some in the store when they are
available in the restaurants they come
in serving sizes of 6 or 12.
well we didn't have that problem in the
u.s or maybe we just don't care either
way loaded potato skins are totally
available at the ustj fridays and they
come in two sizes you can get them eight
or you get the platy boy which is 12.
chicken wings in the uk come in two
portion sizes
as a single portion of three wings
or as a sharing portion
which is six wings
hey harry when i said to compare the
wings between the us and the uk i meant
these wings maybe it's cultural
differences or maybe i just read the
menu wrong
anyway
in the u.s our wings come in an order of
10 or you can get a platter of either 30
or 50 wings
hell yeah dude i want to eat every
single one of these wings
if you like your chicken off the bone
you can also get boneless wings at tgi
fridays in both the uk and the us here
they come in two portion sizes as a
single which is seven ounces or as a
sharing size which is 14 ounces
in the u.s our tgi fridays offer
boneless wings by ounces you can get 10
ounces 40 ounces or a platter of 80
ounces
look at this you have no idea how good
this smells
so good
how does it feel good
the ribs in the uk come in two sizes as
a half rack or as a full rack and both
come in either a legendary or a barbecue
glaze
our ribs in the us also come in a half
slab or a full slab
we're gonna wear a large portion to see
who out of me or joe has the biggest
rack
[Music]
so a large rack of ribs in the uk came
to around 366 grams
a bunch of children over there
joe's rack grow up
all right here we go
this guy's already falling apart
tender
and a full slab in the u.s is almost 600
grams how do you like that i got the
bigger rack
most meals in the uk come with a side of
fries by default so we're going to weigh
a regular portion of fries to see what
it comes to
yikes ours is only 120 120 for a side of
fries in the u.s
here is everything you will only find on
the menu at a uk tgi fridays and this is
everything you can get in the u.s and
not the uk at a tgi fridays let's start
with some appetizers for example over
here we have these which are lightly
spiced shrimp they're just shrimp which
are breaded fried and i presume lightly
spiced it's slightly strange that
they've been referred to as shrimp on
the menu here as it's more common in the
uk to refer to them as prawns it seems
like tj friday's uk have sided with
their american overlords which is
disappointing then we have two garlic
bread options this is a garlic ciabatta
and then this one is a garlic ciabatta
with cheese
pot stickers
these things are so good dude
they're in no way authentic
what a pot sticker should be but in a
category all of its own
does it pretty good the spinach and
artichoke dip this is like classic two
jet fridays right you know we got in the
u.s you don't got in the uk
wing roulette
so what that means is you can get i
think what looks like nine or ten wings
at three different sauces but you can't
tell maybe you could really spice it one
maybe get a mild one you don't know do
you want to play wing wing roulette with
me connor sure there you can take one
paper but wait until i get mine got it
no okay all right buddy ready
wing roulette one two three
i think i got the spicy one oh
oh
yeah i think i got the atomic one
yeah dude that's fun isn't that fun
[Music]
it's fun to torture your friends when
you're out eating we have two exclusive
chicken sandwich options for example
this one which is the californian
chicken club sandwich and then this one
over here which is the louisiana hot
mess sandwich next up we've got some hot
dogs this is the classic american hot
dog there's really not that much to say
about it because it is just a hot dog on
a bun although joe will be excited to
learn that it's not sliced in half it's
a burger with cheese fries on it look
look at this thing i gotta know i have
to know
oh yeah there's bacon too
this was this is good dude
i i would get this at tj fridays i'm
surprised how good this is so we got a
signature whiskey glaze flat iron steak
but that's the glaze sauce right there
and then we got the new york strip the
dragon glazed salmon you got a shot of
this before you know what i noticed i
mean they have this sizzling
chicken and cheese dish so i'm assuming
it goes through like goes to dining room
sizzling on the plate because i notice
tj fridays does not have fajitas i'm
surprised by that so if your u.s tj
fridays has fajitas let me know because
i didn't see them on our menu and i
didn't see them on several other menus
um this is the philly cheesesteak burger
i don't know
oh man this thing's super messy
they got the peppers the onions the
melted cheese
and
what appears to be shredded
beef
and all on top of a burger
no thanks
we have three sides which it looks like
you guys can't get in america we'll
start with these ones from the back
which are the cajun spiced onion rings
while you guys can get onion rings i
thought it was worth pointing out that
these ones are cajun spiced and they're
the only ones available on the uk menu
next up we've got corn on the cob
which comes served with butter and what
looks to be even more cajun seasoning
and then once again we have what is fast
becoming my arch nemesis on this show
which is the sweet potato fry those of
you who've watched episodes before will
probably know that i'm not the biggest
fan of sweet potato fries for this
reason they go super soggy
they are bland
they are not as good as regular fries
and they cost more stop ordering them
broccoli and cheddar soup
yo that's oh man
that's been sitting for a while that
broccoli odor just hit me
cheddar mac and cheese a classic side
then there's also a kids menu hot dog
which is smaller in size but also gives
you the option to add cheese which
personally not convinced is the best
move but udu
some for the kids
get sliders and fries mac and cheese
what youngster doesn't like mac and
cheese come on now
and
pasta one with the marinara and it comes
with a side of either fries or probably
some veggies of fruit i don't know we
also have milkshakes at tgi fridays in
the uk we got two here which are the
oreo shake and the chocolate shake
fridays is known for their signature
drinks they're signature margs so you
can get a tj fridays in the u.s at least
your marks to go in a single
beverage
64 fluid ounces
of friday's margarita hell yeah dude you
know i'm drinking all this tonight thank
you varieties
now the one dessert option we were
actually able to pick up today was this
the chocolate fudge fixation cake
it's a very indulgent looking chocolate
cake with some chocolate icing and also
what looks like a healthy layer of fudge
in the middle you can get this really
fun slice of rainbow cake from i think
it's carlo's bakery rainbow cake look at
that nap bun
that's fun cinnabon
caramel pecan slice of cheesecake dude
this i bet is amazing and i got to give
it up to tgi fridays they were nice
enough that each slice of cake comes
with a scoop of ice cream
it's been a minute
so imagine a scoop of ice cream with
sprinkles in this sorry guys
we don't have a freezer now usually we'd
have a lot more to show you but because
of the pandemic tji fridays in the uk
have reduced their operations so here's
what you would normally be able to find
on top of what we've already shown you
avocado hummus cheesy nachos a ribeye
steak a texan steak garlic chicken king
prawn linguini teriyaki salmon fajitas a
warrior burger with mozzarella sticks in
the burger loaded warrior fries loaded
mario fries roasty potato fries a
s'mores sundae a cookie dough sundae a
new york cheesecake fresh fruit and
orange sorbet sundae and then on the
kids menu you can get fish fingers
chicken burgers bonus bites tomato tubes
chicken wrap vegan meatball penne veggie
burgers create your own dessert chili
billy ice lolly and a fruit cup
[Music]
unfortunately tgi fridays in the uk
doesn't disclose its nutritional
information we were able to find some of
it but that was through third-party
websites and articles for example in the
uk we found that one mozzarella stick
contains 110 calories 6 grams of fat 7
grams of carbs and 4 grams of protein
bringing the total for a side order of
mozzarella sticks to 440 calories
we did get our nutrition information
from tjf fridays and a u.s order of
mozzarella sticks are 840 calories 52
grams of fat 24 of those are saturated
fat 1400 milligrams of sodium and 54
grams of carbs divide all that by six
and one stick is 140 calories while
currently the only available potato
skins are the ones you can find at a
store in the uk if we could get them in
the restaurant one of them is 210
calories bringing an order of 6 to 1 260
calories
and in the us an order of loaded potato
skins is
1510 calories that is 73 grams of fat 23
grams of saturated fat 1950 milligrams
of sodium and 176
grams of carbs
that means that just one skid is 188.75
calories
a standard chicken wing of the uk tgi
fridays is tossed in frank's red hot
sauce and contains 50 calories 3.3 grams
of fat 0.6 grams of carbs and 300
milligrams of sodium bringing a total of
six wings because who's ordering the
three to 300 calories
i don't even like frank's red hot sauce
why do people like i'm sorry it's just
bad way too vinegary acidic i don't want
that from hot sauce i want heat
a standard order of wings at tgi fridays
in the us is tossed in frank's red hot
and is 640
calories 39 grams of fat 11 grams of
saturated fat 2
60 milligrams of sodium three grams of
carbs and if you break that down on
average it is 64 calories per wing if
you decide to get your wings with the
whiskey glaze like i got right here that
brings the total calories up to
830. now you have 40 grams of fat 11
grams of saturated fat 1 300 milligrams
of sodium and 51 grams of carbs now if
you're thinking to yourself i want more
calories
you're in luck just go ahead and get the
garlic parmesan wings that brings the
whole thing up to 960 calories at 71
grams of fat 17 grams of saturated fat
1650 of sodium and 116
grams of carbs hate bones you say scared
of skeletons well if you get boneless
wings instead you are now getting 770
calories that's 42 grams of fat 7 grams
of saturated fat 4 100 milligrams of
sodium and 54 grams of carbs but joe i
need more calories i'm on this cleanse
in which i only eat calories what on
earth can i get you ask glad you did
whiskey glaze that kicks up your
calories at 960. 43 grams of fat 7 grams
of saturated fat 2740 milligrams of
sodium 103
car
bows
i haven't talked for a while now there
are two ribs currently available in the
uk which is the classic ribs with the
legendary glaze made with jack daniels
or the bbq ribs i'd love to tell you
more but unfortunately as i said before
tj friday's in the uk does not disclose
its nutritional information on their
website they instead have this cryptic
message we strive to accommodate all of
our guest's dietary needs and are more
than happy to substitute side dishes for
preferred alternatives you can get their
frozen barbecue ribs at iceland stores
in the uk and as a result we know that
there are 1 103 calories in a box
in the u.s a half rack of signature
whiskey glazed ribs with coleslaw and
fries is 1100 calories 51 grams of fat
15 grams of saturated fat
2180 milligrams of sodium cheese is the
sodium guys and 129 grams of carbs and
if you decide to go with the full record
ribs that brings that whole meal up to
1630 calories that's 75 grams of fat 25
grams of saturated fat 2 940 milligrams
of sodium yo and
178 grams of carbs now while most of the
meals don't have nutritional information
offered it does say on the website that
they offer the nutritional info for the
kids meals so we're going to see if that
is the case
so it turns out that's a lie and they
currently do not have the information
just allergens instead
due to the limited information available
online and also they reduce menu because
of the pandemic we're not sure 100 what
the most calorific menu item is but
we're pretty sure that right now it's
this the whiskey glazed sesame chicken
strips according to the info we found
online a portion of these contains
1840 calories which is 92 of your daily
allowance to burn off the calories in
this dish you'd need to walk for 371
minutes jog for 157 minutes or dance for
313 minutes so
you better get started
the most calorific thing in a tj
friday's in the us that's currently
available due to limited menu options is
this the chicken parm pasta
yo
i don't know about this man
i do not know about this i don't that's
not cheddar cheese is it what is that
this chicken parm pasta has 1 890
calories 107 grams of fat 43 grams of
saturated fat
4130 milligrams of sodium correct me if
i'm wrong but that is the most
sodium-rific thing we've talked about
for this video yes
i think so 4130 milligrams of sodium
that has to be a record
154 grams of carbs 22 grams of sugar and
74 grams of protein now this believe it
or not is not the most calorific menu
item at a tgi fridays in the us that
distinguish honor goes to the chinese
chicken wrap
3570 calories 182 grams of fat 46 grams
of saturated fat
this can't be right 8
220 milligrams of sodium
365 grams of carbs and 83 grams of sugar
so that is twice your daily calories and
your daily fat that's three times your
daily sodium in just one wrap that is
incredible tgi fridays i salute you i
have to try this chicken
[Music]
i have a shocking announcement to make
which is that tj fridays in the uk also
doesn't disclose its ingredients
information
tgi fridays in the us also does not
disclose their ingredients
what do we do now
going in on these wings
i do wish i could dance but
i just can't it's not for me